[موسيقى]
القمم العربيه غالبيتها سميت باسماء المدن
المستضيفه واخرى بالظروف التي تعصف
بالعالم العربي
منها قمه اللاءات الثلاث عقدت في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم في يونيو
1967 عقب عدوان يونيو واحتلال اسرائيل
الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه والجولان وسيناء
القمه السداسيه عقدت في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض في العام
بمبادره من السعوديه والكويت لبحث الازمه
في لبنان قمه الوفاق والاتفاق عقدت في
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان في العام
1987 واطلق عليها هذا الاسم لتعكس الرغبه
في ان تكون القمه للوفاق العربي والاتفاق
قمه الاقصى قمه استثنائيه عقدت في القاهره
في العام 2000 وذلك بعد شهر من اندلاع
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
قمه التضامن عقدت في الرياض في العام 2007
وجرى خلالها التاكيد على الالتزام بالسلام
العادل والشام كخيار استراتيجي
قمه القدس
اطلق عليها الملك سلمان هذا الاسم حيث قال
في كلمته ليعلم القاصي والداني ان فلسطين
وشعبها في وجدان العرب والمسلمين
قمه لم الشمل عقدت في الجزائر في نوفمبر
2022 وهي الاولى بعد انقطاع دام نحو ثلاث
سنوات
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات